ちょっとですね用事があって
今からタクシー乗って
たくさん荷物持って遠出するんですけども
今日はちょっと実験的にですね
タクシーに乗るんですけども
そのタクシーの運転手さんを
僕の笑いの技術で
笑わせれるかどうかっていうのを実験してみたいと思います
わけ分かんない企画だね
自分でも何やってるんだろうと思っちゃうよ
ルールは簡単ですよ
とりあえず今からタクシーを呼んで乗って遠くに行くんですけども
まあタクシーの運転手さんも色々いるんですよ
すっごいあのーすごい堅い人もいれば
すごい楽しそうに喋ってくれる人もいるんで
一概にねこれは上手くいくかどうかっていうのは結構僕次第でもあるんですけど
運転手さん次第ってとこもあるんですよ
上手くいけばいいなーくらいの感じで
実験的にね
とりあえず俺の笑いのテクニックを皆に伝えたいよ
とりあえず電話します
あ、すいません　配車お願いします
というわけでですねもう少しでタクシーが来るんですけども
俺の..あっやべ
俺のね笑いのテクニック
貴様らに見せてやるぜ
たまんないね
へっへっ
運転手：東京行くだ（方言？）
はじめ：そうなんすよ
運転手：なんかあれなのなんかあのーなに
運転手：アイドルかなんかの
はじめ：いやいやそんな
はじめ：僕
はじめ：YouTubeって知ってます？
運転手：YouTube..
はじめ：あれになんか動画を上げてて
運転手：自分は投稿した？
はじめ：僕してますしてます
運転手：あそーー
運転手：俺タブレット持ってるもんでよく見るよ
はじめ：え、本当ですか？
運転手：そうだよ
運転手：どんなものを？
はじめ：いやなんか本当に変なことばっりかしてます
アッハッハッハッハッ
運転手：暇だとよく見てるよー
はじめ：あ、本当ですか？
運転手：うん、見てる見てる
はじめ：僕ですか？
運転手：うん
はじめ：部屋にピッチングマシーンをセットして
はじめ：部屋で150kmのバッティングしたり
運転手：おおん？
運転手：部屋の中で？
はじめ：部屋の中でです
運転手：ピッチングマシーンを？
はじめ：はいはい
運転手：それで部屋の中でそれをなに打つ？
はじめ：部屋で打つっていう
運転手：150kmって見えないじゃんもう
はじめ：見えないんですよホント怖かったですよ
はじめ：やりましたやりました
運転手：当たった？ほいで（それで）
はじめ：いや無理でした　速すぎて
運転手：アイドルっちゃアイドルだなもう
はじめ：いやいやアイドルではないですけど
運転手：ほんとだよなんかー
運転手：じゃあ後で見るよ
はじめ：あーありがとうございます
運転手：そう
運転手：実家どこ？
はじめ：実家（は）富山です
運転手：あー富山
運転手：今今あれだちょっと話題になってるな
運転手：北陸新幹線で
はじめ：あーそうですね
運転手：うちの娘も金沢なんだけどさ
はじめ：あ、そうなんですか
運転手：仕事でね単身だよ
運転手：単身たってそういうもんだからね
運転手：単身なっちゃったけど
運転手：金沢はまた違うんだよね富山とはねちょっとね
はじめ：そうですね、金沢（は）都会っぽいですね
運転手：長いこと住んでるよーもうレオパレスで
はじめ：おおー僕もレオパレスなんです
運転手：東京行ってアイドルなっちゃえばいいじゃんおいー
はじめ：いやいや無理ですよアイドルは
運転手：なーんでー
はじめ：アイドルはちょっと厳しいですよ
運転手：厳しいのかー？
はじめ：ダンスとか歌とかできないんで
運転手：そりゃレッスンするだがいね
はじめ：えーー大変そうだな
運転手：そっちの方がいんじゃねー？
はじめ：ホントですか？
運転手：うーーん
はじめ：アイドルなろうかなー
運転手：嫌いか
はじめ：いやちょっと
運転手：なれたらいいじゃんなー
はじめ：アイドルじゃあ目指しますか
運転手：目指した方がいんじゃないかー？
はじめ：本当ですか？
運転手：良い男だよねー
はじめ：えーーそんなまたまた
運転手：ホントだよ
はじめ：照れますよ
運転手：そんなことはねぇよ
はじめ：いやいややめてください
運転手：ホントに
はじめ：やめてください照れます照れます
運転手：いいよーいいなぁ～
はじめ：いいですか？ありがとうございます
運転手：ホントに良い子だよなー
運転手：これは後で見とくからな
はじめ：あ、ありがとうございます
運転手：忘れ物だけはしないようにな
はじめ：はい、ありがとうございます
運転手：届けないよー東京まで
えーー是非是非
運転手さんを笑わせれるかどうかっていう企画だったんですけど
なんか良い感じに終わっちゃいました
アッッッハッハッ
はじめ：ありがとうございました
運転手：いえいえいえ
はじめ：ありがとうございましたー楽しかったです
行ってきまーす